those ones you pretty much just have to
remember them and use them not that big
a deal but this guy is going to be will
run this set the code is that you're
going to work on baby you really have to
understand what's going on so what I
want you to recall is we said if you're
in a write a word triangle that's great
but your feature is limited to 90
degrees for cute angles that's what you
got right and we said that's kind of not
good enough angles can be much bigger
than that so what can we do advantage
running triangular we mentioned our unit
circle now I want you to write down for
me
books on color the unit circle the unit
circle lives on the Cartesian plane and
I can write its equation in Cartesian
form if a unit circle is centered at the
origin and its radius is 1 and therefore
the equation of the unit circle is can
anyone stop if x squared plus y squared
1 equals it really is 1 squared over T
but we know what ones where it is so we
just write this one okay so there's the
in a circle but you guys told me we
redefine what with prints off in terms
of that time we said actually the x
coordinate of a point on a circle is a
tradition and the y coordinate is also a
tradition which ones which yeah so this
is cosine this is sine the way I
remember it's many times is just like x
and y is now the medical so it actually
is cos theta I can write x squared as
colored squares here and if Y is sine
theta then I can write 1 where as I
square it it equals to 1 now you can
quickly confirm this edges like this off
inside let's pick a value one that we
know like st. Peter equals 30 degrees
it's VR
people thirty degrees right I treasured
exact values into sort of flex your
muscles with it
what's cause been close the big thing
pretty sure it's Route 3 on 2 so I'm
going to have root 3 on 2
yeah that's close though I can sweat
that interesting science it on the other
half pad that's half right so here is my
sign squared with right so what happens
as we evaluated route through to when
you square it you get three quarters
uh-huh when you square it you get and
sure enough okay you can turn any value
you like that's the thing about is
identity is always true you guys are put
in nicely numbers duty calculator and
put in cos squared xx degrees plus sine
square trainer I know I do a point for
your central yard but when you square
them and atom and guarantee you get one
so this guy here would be box around it
this is what I call the primary
hypergravity this is the one that gives
birth to the others so it's the one you
eat remember but you can get two
versions on
[Music]
okay now these two versions these people
they just want to say look this is a
great identity life but it only relates
to time and so I know a whole bunch of
other tricks function by 62 so how do I
get them in on the game please what I'm
going to do I don't think it's helping
and I'm going to buy left hand side and
right hand side by cos square everything
will turn watch what happens jiminee
continue divided contra by parts where
you get one when you divide sine square
by Chi square by definition that ten
squares you agree when you divide one by
cos squared by definition that is six
squared okay now this is another version
of the piper going I did it we just got
it from here I'm provided through so
it's still the same thing so long as cos
V dot isn't zero budget divided two
micro spirit so I better not be zero but
that's another measures which we use for
if what you're provided with nothing out
sine and cosine dinner maybe hand tan
and sex in it so if you want to
manipulate those guys this is a version
that you use I should point out I just
found embarrassing but after how many
years of doing maths that are doing it I
still doesn't remember this I just write
this down because it's really easy to
get this right and then I do exactly
what I just told you what device you
micron square if you want to remember
this and memorize it then Joseph your
life however I don't need to write this
it will equally be used like this and
whereas data equals x squared theta
minus 1 and is often useful as well but
you can see it's really easy to go to
juice like is not a minus or is that a -
we're going to plus can you see why it's
tough to get you're busy and when you
have it along with everything else on
the board it's easy to muddle up in your
head if you remember this and get
everything else you want screw it on so
that's - now what do I do to get - yes
again whether the less you're back on I
divided by cos square which then implies
another useful way to get something out
of this is divided by square so when you
do that whole square is divided by sine
squared by definition is side squared
divided by x squared is 1 1 and then on
the right hand side 1 divided by science
ready and there's another version if the
thing that you've been handed to work
with has cost and correct in it
then this is a version that you will use
provided a course provider divided
through by this that sine theta is not 0
okay you divides you by something to
introduce a restriction